il faut briller dit je suis candidat à
la présidence de la région c'est simple
est-ce que je voterai pour lui
bon c'est plus simple de dire comme ça
non je ne voterai pas pour lui parce que
je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui que
voilà et maintenant j'ai la tête de
barack obama et vous avez pleuré mardi
dernier os il va vraiment manqué barack
obama peut à la fois parce qu'avec trump
on va se rendre compte de la chance que
l'on avait puis parce qu'il y avait la
classe quoi bernie sanders à ce que j'y
ai cru oui j'ai oui j'y ai cru et j'y
crois encore je pense que lui aurait
battu tron parce que moi c'est clair ils
perpétuent pas le système vous en pensez
quoi
ben on paye aujourd'hui le prix
d'avoir menti la france peut battre
l'australie samedi
bien sûr je pense qu'on a une grosse
équipe puis surtout on a un bon
entraîneur bon esprit moi je suis très
confiant oui vous voyez vraiment trois
points communs avec jean luc mélenchon
bas il a été un peu plus longtemps pour
moi au parti socialiste
j'aime son
non j'aime sa constance trois
différences avec arnaud je suis pas
productiviste un peu moins souverainiste
et
on n'a pas la même femme c'est toi qui
garde qui gère ton instagram
sur cette photo oui aux mollahs beaucoup
reproché donc maintenant un peu moins la
séparation des frérots de la vega ça
vous fait quoi
ça désespère ma fille ma grand'mère les
pactes et encore l'école élémentaire
mais voilà les désespérer vous
connaissez j'ai soit parce que je
connais non arnaud vincent emmanueli
barbara et moi le stade gic nouveau
parti socialiste ou oui et non oui parce
que l'on voie semblait et voilà c'était
c'était bien là aujourd'hui on n'a pas
plus divisé tue dir écho aux jeunes
amants qu'est-ce que dire au jeune homme
alors fait le recommence macron et tiên
macro il est classique tellement
classique shit ou ben moi je suis pour
légaliser les deux voilà donc après
chacun choisira mais je pense qu'il vaut
mieux consacrer l'argent à la prévention
et à l'éducation plutôt que la
répression
votre meilleure amie à droite
j'aime bien le maire voilà j'aime bien
le maire bruno le maire je trouve
voilà j'aime bien le bonhomme ton pire
ennemi en politique extrême droite sont
tous ces visages quel qu'il soit vous
serez vous dans dix ans je sais pas
surveillez le bac de ma fille